reclaman verdad de justicia las víctimas
de la dictadura cívico-militar en
uruguay
exigen el procesamiento de los
responsables décadas después del golpe
militar los afectados todavía piden
justicia ante la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos ya que los autores de
los crímenes no han sido juzgados en la
república oriental de uruguay se precia
de ser una de las democracias plenas en
américa latina' y si bien tiene varios
motivos para hacerlo en lo que respecta
al pasado reciente
uruguay mantiene hasta el día de hoy una
deuda que se profundiza en cada día que
pasa sin respuestas concretas y
efectivas desde el 27 de junio de 1973
en uruguay se cometieron crímenes contra
la humanidad el caso de las muchachas de
abril es uno entre tantos en diciembre
del 74 tres activistas de entre 19 y 21
años fueron asesinadas tras recibir más
de 200 balazos en un operativo de las
fuerzas armadas y la policía como ellas
hay muchas otras que sufrieron abusos
víctimas que ahora denuncian la
violencia a la que están expuestas las
en estos conflictos porque el cuerpo de
la mujer
louis y es en este momento a un botín de
guerra ellos tenían un doble
doble castigo a la mujer
primero
por ser mujer
son algunas de las 28 víctimas que
llevaron su caso ante la cidh junto a
cientos de familiares de otras víctimas
que también exigen responsabilidades
torturas interrogatorios plantones son
algunos de los delitos que acusan y
contra los que los uruguayos han salido
a las calles en repetidas ocasiones a lo
largo de estos años pidiendo al estado
que responda ante estas acciones y
brinde justicia a las familias